I haven't covered this story in and of
itself but I have talked a little bit
about how I see the appearance at the
Emmys on Sunday by former press
secretary for Donald Trump Sean Spicer
as really problematic because it was all
about you bring out out Sean and he
pokes fun when he said the inauguration
crowd for Donald Trump was the biggest
ever and in doing so it sort of seems
like he knows that wasn't really true
and we all have a good time because
after all the guy's not working for
Trump anymore and I believe that it is
very very dangerous to do this in the
same way by the way that I've said just
because George W Bush seems
comparatively reasonable compared to
Donald Trump doesn't mean that now we
need to remember George W Bush as having
been some great president who did
amazing things it's important to keep
sort of a connection to reality and I
believe that allowing Sean Spicer to
appear in this teddy bear way walking
out with his dumb podium on the Emmys
furthered the idea that he's a good guy
and he wasn't really out there
perpetrating lie after lie after lie on
the American people which he was he's
still a terrible person who was
complicit in the entire thing who ruined
his career hopefully although maybe not
because we've seen people who seemed to
ruin their careers in politics end up
actually getting pretty good jobs from
someone so he did an interview with ABC
where I don't even know how this is
something he can say with a straight
face he's claiming he never knowingly
lied to the American people in all of
those press briefings that were riddled
with lies here's Sean Spicer some argue
that the reason you did it is because
this is step one in trying to rehab your
image I feel very good with my image I'm
very happy with myself I am able to go
out and explain a lot of things now but
I'm not on a tour I'm out having some
fun it might be fun for Spicer but not
for his many critics people have hard
feelings for Stan because they feel that
you lied to the American people have you
ever lied to the American people I don't
think so
you don't think so no I'm cheering my
taxes unequivocally you can say no I
look again you want to find something
I've not knowingly done anything to to
do that no I haven't cheated on my taxes
Sean she's talking about in your role as
the spokesperson for the President of
the United States for me as soon as he
said I haven't cheated on my taxes that
means you know you lied to the American
people when you were press secretary
well here's the thing he may be telling
the truth in his response because as the
press secretary he's really just
parroting the words of the
administration oh he's a conduit it just
shows that he has no skepticism no
critical thinking to verify the facts
before he goes out there and tells the
American public that's interesting if
you believe that he is merely a conduit
for the assertions of the president then
these weren't really his statements he's
just out there saying this is the
position of the White House which is
crazy because that would mean he's
having it both ways because so many
times we hear from both heard from Sean
Spicer and hear from Sarah Huckabee
Sanders his replacement that they can't
speak for the president that well that's
your job your job is to speak for the
president you can't possibly have it
both ways
he's lying about lying right and I'm
actually confused because the entire
Emmy thing this is the biggest Emmy
audience ever it's only funny if it's
poking fun of the fact that it wasn't
true when he said it about the
inauguration right and again this
reinforces the idea that conservatives
just don't get satire and parody and it
continues here's more of Sean Spicer in
this bizarre Gong Show interview look I
made mistakes there's no question I
think we all do some of them I tried to
own very publicly and in some cases
there were things that I did that until
someone brought it up I said gosh I
didn't realize that that was a mistake
I'm sorry about that but to watch some
of the personal attacks questioning my
integrity questioning my does you know
what my intentions were I think we're
really over the top later he was told
some of the things he said might have
been inaccurate day one could he truly
have thought that it was the largest
inauguration crowd ever just on day one
there are multiple lies just in this
portion of the interview about lying
probably including I feel very good with
my image maybe that's true but
I have a hard time believing that with
this level of dishonesty how his Fox
News not snatched this guy up and signed
him to a 5-year deal right
I really hope at some point Sean Spicer
is asked about lying to the American
people in front of a grand jury
I really just don't believe that if Sean
Spicer knew that he was about to tell a
lie and instructed by the White House to
do so
that he would have the integrity to
fight back I don't even say I'm not
gonna go out there because he would know
that Trump would bash him and possibly
even fire him and Trump ended up bashing
him anyway right Spicer went out there
and told the lie about the inauguration
crowd and Trump apparently didn't like
the way he did it because he didn't
think it was a good performance I think
that Sean Spicer could much better use
his time looking for a lawyer than doing
these weird interviews he is a meta liar
not Megha Mehta he is lying about lying
is there any way that we could believe
Sean Spicer doesn't think he lied let me
know I'm on Twitter at D Pakman we'll be
back after this
today's program is made possible in part
by independent artist types from Grand
Rapids Michigan with the war ep the war
EP is a multi John ray
progressive humanist response to the
ongoing culture war in America let's
listen to a sample of the song not a
person
[Music]
everything
no it's not
when I heard the song and thought of the
concept not a person I was thinking
about the concept unperson which i think
is from Orwell's 1984 right I may be
wrong about that but anyway that's like
the whole vibe of the war EP album and
you can hear the song in its entirety at
types that's types with forties types
Bandcamp calm you can also find
exclusive demos and live recordings on
the types patreon and YouTube pages both
of which also have forties